so this is Comic Con week any surprises
you can tease for what you guys are
doing at comic-con and any any news that
people not attending should be looking
out for um I know that we're going to be
showing a cool clip at our panel that
that I think people are going to really
get a kick out of
we have a lot I mean it's a very
frequent conversation to have to the
Riggin morty room it's a very very
frequent thing that happens it is
someone saying something crazy maybe
even as what's called a room bit like
which is typically an unusable kind of
thing but then you know as they're
finishing it everyone going out why do
you why not I think that's a very
healthy room to be in I know that like I
can't remember what the origin of pickle
brick was but I think it was something
like that that's a big likely I mean I
was probably the peak of season three of
our health are kind of yes and because
someone said he turns himself into a
pickle and instead of any energy being
put into what I wouldn't work you know I
just remembered a certain point I've
gotten really excited about it as the
kind of like you know the episode of
Breaking Bad where they're stuck in the
RV and the opportunities that those sort
of not only bottle episodes but I mean
this is anything but a bottle episode
the pickle Rick's thing but that RV
episode of Breaking Bad
it gets very granular about the inside
workings of Walter White's mind and so
we got excited about about Rick's
turning himself into a pickle for that
yeah but what was your
like something that something that it
was I don't know if this was so much
like you know I now come on but
seriously kind of a thing but the the
board girlfriend was something that we
were trying to break in season one the
unity episode but it wasn't anywhere
near what we ultimately ended up doing
in season two but that was definitely
ample of an idea that that we had at
least a seed of you know the idea of
Rick dating this hive minded you know
entity in season one and couldn't quite
crack it I think you're on harmontown
tour and I remember really Ridley and I
were trying to like figure that thing
out and then it just wasn't quite where
it needed to be but in any case it came
back and season two we brought it we
were like moment about that do we
actually do that properly and then I
don't know I think the only other one I
can think of is the lighthouse keeper
more akin to the you know what you're
describing which is like the you know
we're laughing or crying but we're like
okay no but seriously we can't have a
second act when they go and sit
listening to an old man in a lighthouse
read a screenplay like come on we got it
like let's really figure out the
second act here and then like we just
kept tough to do it we kept on going
back to the later maybe we would talk
for like ten minutes about other ways it
could go and then it would just continue
to circle back around to the lighthouse
keeper and and for no other reason that
it was just fun and it was just laughing
accepting poignant - it could be like a
write what you don't think because when
you think about courage mythologies you
think well this is about savagery of
society and the hypocrisy of the the
pretense of law and order and thing and
then one thing that's never visited in
those purge movies or in any kind of
purge type of sci-fi episode is the fact
that some of the loftiest
high-mindedness nerds the people that
are that would hide from the purge and
stander their bed and lament society
savagery might be the first people who
would just go off about a Wonder Woman
movie or something that didn't like this
their definition of their
culture religion and mourning ends up
pushing a guy now this fear because
extreme plays felt horrible and he can
get away with it could be purging
restrict praising him and more he's like
no that's not what I was doing that talk
about a little about your favorite guest
stars for the season
oh oh that's a good question um we've
got some pretty amazing people Thomas
Middleditch is going to be featured in
episode the season Susan Sarandon mmm
who else read Danny Trejo we got Peter
Serafinowicz Christian Slater since
later for you community fans and
actually for fans have just great
wonderful people Joel McHale has been an
episode and Killian Jacobson's in
another episode
yeah and I guarantee you were forgetting
Keith David reprises his role as the GD
president of the MFN United States which
is a you know it's probably going to
confuse people that don't buy I mean I I
never considered Keith's character an
analog for Obama like I don't see the
world through that lens I groove
literally was it was just a trope of the
strong president on that you see in
movies i but but it it surely will be
like people will be like wait there you
supposed to be Obama or did you say ever
say his actual name it's just mr.
president yeah I don't even ever say is
me yeah it's fantastic I love that
character for you dr. who say and it's
like like the leftenant that would in
place
the tom baker doctor who occasionally to
display so good I love that role in the
sci-fi wanderer series of the local
terrestrial government official who
needs help sometimes yeah bogs and down
and like fighting the Loch Ness monster
or something hey youtubers happy Comic
Con Week continues and there is a new
round of that merch giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so they
basically just dropped all those guest
stars a whole bunch of people from
community Danny Trejo Peter Serafinowicz
Christian Slater is an interesting one
that makes me wonder if they're going to
do a mr. robot episode but they confirm
they're going to drop a comic-con
trailer during their panel they might
post that online they might not but
we're less than 10 days away from the
premiere as I'm posting this so there
will be new promos if you're down at
Comic Con they're also screening the
episodes at Petco Park but I think it's
just a repeat of episode 1
the special footage they're talking
about is probably from episode 2 or from
a future episode but they make it sound
like it's a single clip from a single
episode and not just a bunch of stuff
cut together but what will happen is is
that panel is on Friday I'll do a video
for whatever it is they have there been
a lot of things happening at Comic Cons
they just haven't panned out people
haven't brought footage for anything so
it makes doing videos a little bit
easier it's always easier when there's
less stuff that I have to worry about so
if you have any special comic-con
requests just leave them in the comments
below but there'll be new rick and morty
coming on Friday I'll be adding stuff to
my Comic Con playlist at the top of my
channel so you see all the regular comic
book stuff for Marvel DC the movies the
TV shows I'll just be adding it to that
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner supersonic bread please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here to re-watch the rick and
morty season 3 trailer and you can click
here for all my other comic-con trailer
videos starting with the punisher thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome i'll see you guys this weekend
[Music]
[Applause]